wir haben jetzt auch gegessen und jetzt
gehe ich auch doni akt nein wieso geht
es nicht
wie oder was jay carney und heute geht
es zu den video der ist nach berlin
heute bzw
morgen sind ja erst heute ist die
anreise und ich produziere nicht vor
sondern macht dieses blogs hier
hochladen durch ein problem werden wir
sind weil man dort in der wohnung und
wir werden jede menge andere youtuber
treffen in den nächsten tag nicht ja
gespannt darauf und hier ist mein koffer
ich habe schon gepackt und dann würde
ich mal sagen los
so leute wir sind hier in berlin
das ist ziemlich eklige sweater und da
drin steht luca der hat mir nicht
gesehen luca ja also das wirklich gut
volk von watson
mit für erfurt geboren
ich mag das nicht getan ist wir sind
hier meine freunde bei techsmith weist
das ganze das sind groß piraten sonstwas
und monatlich glaubt sie zu kennen
gelernt bei den bamberger battle und es
ist so cool darum was man alles so
alphabetisch und hast auch überall
überall sind süßigkeiten was ist richtig
cool wie immer weg aber ja wir machen
gleich vielleicht auch so einen drohen
schlacht also jetzt erst mal mit den
jungs hier und da vielleicht ergibt sich
ja man weiß es nicht und finde ich bin
ich darf jetzt auf meine heimliche auch
noch ok in dein gesicht
zwischendrin pflege es in meinem kopf
her pflege mein herz rein
wir sind hier im coolsten büro der welt
oder lukas was ist das hier muss
crossing denn die werden sich arbeiten
befürchtet seinem arbeitsplatz und für
noch mehr tun aber risiko und die kicker
das so cool irgendwie luca will auch
hier arbeiten definitiv
wir haben jetzt auch gegessen jetzt gehe
ich auf drohen lacht nein diese werte
nicht
ok also leute verabschieden uns jetzt
von unseren tollen gastgeber wirklich
ein sehr sehr lustige haben
der kurs gibt sie bestimmt einiges
so leute wir sind hier jetzt in der nähe
von der pate von endemol und es ist drin
fucking laut und man muss wenn man
draußen stehen werde ungefähr zwei meter
weg laufen aber an sich ist die party
ganz cool da drin ist es so eng und so
wahrscheinlich nicht zuviel filmen kann
denke mal das war vielleicht zeige ich
euch noch so ein paar impressionen jetzt
sondern wasser vielleicht kann ich auch
kein film aber würde ich sagen was er
vom ersten die die welt wieder anders
geworden ist
und ja wir haben alle noch getroffen im
regie felix sich also hier sind so viele
youtube 250 leute